getting rahman welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
about subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be
experts we ask the experts
we're here at the world-famous angel
comedy club and our amazing expert guest
this week is Gideon Rahman who's the
chief foreign affairs commentator for
the Financial Times a renowned author
and winner of the oil prize for
political journalism getting rahman
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much
didn't tell us a little bit about how
you are where you are what was what's
your background what's been your journey
to to this place um Wow in way quite
conventional but like a lot of things is
sort of a bit of chance and bit of luck
chucked in so God what is my background
so well I was born in London but my
parents were South Africans South
African Jews and their parents had been
Lithuanian Latvian so it's kind of
typical immigrant story there was a
whole bunch of Lithuanian Latvian Jews
who I think intended to go to America
and got on the wrong boat and ended up
in South Africa so you know okay so they
were there and then for my good fortune
because he didn't particular even as a
white person grew up in apartheid South
Africa it's quite a screwed up place my
dad was a academic moved to Britain
before I was born I was born here and
then yeah you know I did the kind of
conventional path to the BBC I guess I
want history but I but I was also I was
fortunate in the sense that you know I
now see with my kids a lot of scratch
and I was I was kind of knew I want to
be a journalist very early on I was a
respected profession back then yeah cuz
well I know I didn't mean that as an
insult right now I get the sense that
otally fair question ya know cuz in a
slightly creepy I was a really sort of
creepy eight-year-old I think it was a
like a you know a respectable thing to
do then but say yeah so then so that
then meant that I wasn't quite kind of
focused about getting the right things
on my CV editing the student paper and
then I got a job at the BBC World
Service when I left which was like the
biggest fringe element of the BBC I if
it's you know I got rejected for the
mainstream bit of the BBC for ITN for
writers etc
got a last thing and did that for a
while and actually that was good because
it made although was the most obscure
bit of the BBC it was concerned with
international affairs and so that got me
interested in not doing domestic
politics but looking in the wider world
and then for mixture sort of personal
and professional reasons decided to
leave the BBC and go freelance and go to
Washington though the personal bit was
my girlfriend then our wife was studying
at Georgetown so I wanted to be with her
and also I wanted to get to America and
I wanted to be in print and then you
know a couple of lucky breaks along the
way so the paper I went mainly to write
for when bankrupt after 18 months is
paper called the Sunday correspondent
and I kind of in the moment of
desperation picked up the phone and just
rang everybody I knew and said how you
know I need a job and as it turned out
the guy doing that sort of deputy editor
of the US section of the Economist had
gone that week and so that the door
opened at the right time and then I was
at the Economist for 15 years and that
that was good because I had a couple of
foreigner foreign correspondent jobs
particularly one in Asia which I had
been very West centric both in the kind
of history I studied you know Europe
America and then where I wanted to go on
to get straight to the US and then they
said Oh will you be bank correspondent
nischelle okay but I went and it was a
good time to go as early the early 90s
and so the boom in Southeast Asia had
happened and the boom in China was just
beginning
and although Thailand's actually a few
hours flight from China it's a very
powerful ethnic Chinese business
community who were very tuned into what
was going on so I quite quickly got
interested in this what was clearly kind
of world-changing development and it was
the right time to get interested in it
because it's something I then follow for
like 20 years on and your latest book is
about yeah so so yeah I wrote this book
called Eastern ization was slightly
unwieldy title but the conceit is that
you know we've had 500 years where the
whole world is westernizing and because
of the shift in economic power to Asia
we're going to begin to Eastern eyes
that the power of influence of Asia or
in the world particularly of China but
not just China India countries of
Southeast Asia is going to grow it's
going to start with economics but it'll
move into
politics culture and so on and already
is happening and and how do you see the
world you talk and that's a really
fascinating term Eastern izing because
we obviously we use westernized a lot
but that's not a term that I
particularly heard but bearing in mind
that China isn't a democracy how do you
think that's gonna affect us in the West
I think it's gonna affect us more than
we've reckoned you know we thought well
you know we'll sell him some staff and
it's fine and they'll burned and then we
had to I think illusions which you know
obviously history is not written so we
can't be sure but we there was there was
a period particularly our early period
in the 90s was talking about what
Western Conference was very high because
the Berlin Wall had just fallen and we
thought okay look particularly if the
Chinese embrace capitalism that their
society will become much more diverse
individualism all rise up and they'll
have to become a democracy or the whole
thing will come crashing down it'll just
happen and if they become a democracy
well you know problem over there we'll
all get on and I think both those jumps
in the argument were mistaken we are see
we were wrong to assume that they could
that capitalism would necessarily entail
liberalization the political system was
still waiting you know
2018 and anything that's becoming more
authoritarian that's right I was just
about to mention yeah he's just
basically seized power forever yeah the
right summation of it yeah more or less
I mean I you will see but he's certainly
giving himself the ability to do it
they've changed the Chinese Constitution
and the Chinese you know although they
never said that we that we will become
democratic they did say or the kind of
official line you would hear in Beijing
is well we've solved the problem of
succession that you know the problem
with obviously what the authoritarian
countries keep running into is
eventually you get a sort of Stalin or
Mao who just sits then and screws the
whole place up and it's a disaster and
they said no we have got a collective
leadership now if the Communist Party
and the leader will change every eight
years and we've done it two times no we
had you know done step down and then you
had Jung's amend for eight years and
then he stepped down and then who's in
town for eight years see it works you
know and then I said you know why not
step down and and so suddenly and of
course they're all having to pretend
it's fine
we're with this but in fact a lot of
Chinese liberals and they exist are are
dismayed really dismayed because they
sort of are very worried about the
direction the country is going now but
equally and it quite sinisterly for us
and it comes back the question you asked
well does this begin to affect us one of
the ways that that Xi Jinping is
consolidating power is by stoking up
nationalism and saying you know China's
strong again we're standing up for
ourselves we're gonna reclaim these
territories we should have had and you
know they're not as dangerous or as
aggressive as the Russians in their
behavior I think partly because they're
playing a longer game I think mine sort
of one of the ways I read Russian
behavior is they feel like knifes at
their throat and that they've got to do
anything whatever I mean I I don't agree
with their assessment but that's their
sort of view I think the Chinese feel on
the on the Roth differently that they're
in the ascendancy and they're not going
to screw it up so by frightening the
West too much they're just gonna
gradually build up a position of
strength
now Trump's really disrupted that but by
the trade war he's declared because just
as we assumed that China would become
democratic wrongly they maybe not assume
but Sony hoped and built their policy
around the idea that the West would keep
its markets open because you know
whatever that we either genuinely
believed in globalization or that the
mutual economic interests would would
persuade everyone to do that and now
Trump's come in and said you know I'm
gonna slap tariffs on steel and
aluminium I'm gonna block you on
intellectual property and so on and how
China responds to that is gonna be a big
big story in the next five to ten years
because I think it's potentially kind of
dangerous I don't buy the idea that free
trade guarantees peace but it creates a
intersection of interests which makes it
much less likely that countries will
start you know going to war if the
Chinese feel actually now the Americans
are trying to take down their economy in
some way they're much less there's much
less incentive for them to say go easy
in the South China Sea
for example which the Americans still
regard as the
an American Lake as some American guy
put it to me in the Pentagon but it's a
curious thing because if you remember
kill cannot mix last year you remember
Harold Mangrum who's the father of one
of our future guests Pippa Magnum he was
talking about the fact that he felt that
Obama was weak on this South China Sea
and what he was talking about is
basically the Americans can see through
the satellites exactly what's happening
there and the Chinese would
incrementally step up their presence
they would see that there was no
response even though they knew that the
Americans had seen what was happening
and what when what we're now seeing is
an emboldened China as a result of
Obama's presence well you know so many
different he's right to a degree but I
don't think Obama would have been
correct to challenge them but there's a
different their different ways of
looking at it he's right
what he's right about is that the
Chinese did it very cleverly because
they moved incrementally in each little
step would not be enough to confront
them on and I remember talking to an
Obama guy who was [ __ ] was following
all this and he was a you know to senior
advisor he said to me now how am I meant
there was the time they were worrying
about something called a second Thomas
shoal which is something that the
Philippines used to reinsert their
claims anyway it's a sunken ship which
they resupply as a way of saying you
know this bitter waters Filipino and
they were that the Americans were
worried that the Chinese were going to
sort of sink the ship or something crazy
like that anyway this guy said to me how
am I meant to go and tell the president
that he should risk a war with China
over a sunken battleship in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean which is underwater
half the time he's not gonna do it
and he's right not to do it but so what
the Chinese did was overtime advance
advance advance and each little step
creates sort of facts in the water but
then I think there's a broader question
of well you know are they you know you
said wonderfully arrogant common
American Lake yeah maybe the Americans
should just say you know what we have
dominated the Pacific since 1945 but
China's rising it's not going to be like
that anymore and we should come to some
sort of
tacit agreement with them about or maybe
even explicit agreement about spheres of
influence and so on because otherwise
the only other way to stop that is to
eventually to have a war with them and
we're not up for that so I don't that's
the debate that's got to be hairy and
China is a communist country but having
been to China it's in many ways the most
consumerist capitalist society that I've
ever encountered in my life I mean what
could you explain that dichotomy a
little bit for us as to yeah you can be
both communist and you know have a Gucci
bag on you yeah well that that's that's
their genius
no I'll look guys I would say they're
communists only politically now in the
sense that they're or even Leninist that
they believe in a one-party state with
with a sort of communist party structure
which is a very real thing so that you
know that in universities for example
the Communist Party operates ambitious
students will join the Communist Party
organisation companies will have a
communist party member on the board you
know it's it's it's a thing but it's a
it's a mechanism of political control
rather than an economic system anymore
and I think that there are probably
still vestiges of the sense that well
we're doing it for the people you hear
that in say she's rhetoric about their
greatest claim is how many people
they've lifted out of poverty hundreds
of millions they will say and I think
the World Bank would agree and they'll
so that's sort of communism by other
means communism by capitalist means but
trying to create more wealth and so you
know I don't think they're completely
cynical but but I would say they're
communists primarily in in political
so I'll guess what we'll start with is
Trump is in power at the moment Russia
are behaving like a super villain in a
cheap Airport novel and we have King
jeong-hoon in charge of North Korea um
it's the world coming to the end or is
this how it's always been it's
definitely not how it's always been I
mean it feels like a very strange time I
mean I guess for me the defining period
of my sort of adult life journalistic
career was 1989 you know the fall of the
Berlin Wall and so on and that marked
the end of a period that I'd grown up in
the Cold War and then really I'd say
from 89 to 2008 there was a sort of
continuity we felt like you know
famously Fukuyama's that there was the
end of history even if that's a bit of
an overstatement but that the Western
ideas had triumphed the West was pretty
stable the rest of the world was kind of
you know the number of democracies
around the world was increasing
generally people thought globalization
was a good good thing of you know a bit
of a generalization but but thinks that
felt pretty stable and I think you have
the financial crisis and I think that
for me was one of the triggers for
things to begin to go wrong but but when
you know you mentioned Russia behaving
like a supervillain etc etc of Kim
jong-un but for me the really disturbing
thing about the current period is not so
much that there are rogue nations there
always have been but what's going on
inside the West I mean it would have
been unimaginable really until very
recently that somebody like Donald Trump
could become president of the United
States mainly actually because of his
personal style which I think sends a
very negative political message but also
he is reversing all sorts of kind of
shibboleths of American foreign policy
about free trade whatever and then I
think there's also wider rot in in the
West I mean III think that the whole
connection remember accident Trump's a
complicated one but there is some sort
of connection in in the sense of
discontent that fired it but equally if
you look into Europe I mean the politics
of countries that seem relatively stable
- quite recently Spain Italy looking
really dodgy and and in Eastern Europe
countries that we thought okay they've
joined the Democratic camp pretty solid
now Hungary is really I think slipping
away from democracy Poland aren't
you plea as well and then finally you've
got this
I think sense in the West which maybe is
sort of loosely connected to what's
going on generally that our period as
the dominant bloc in the world Europe in
the u.s. is is coming to a close you've
got the rise of a new power in China
which is now by some measures the
largest economy in the world you've got
a much more assertive India and in
themselves those didn't fit theirs
needn't be threatening things but China
does is not a democracy is in a way a
kind of wounded country which has a lot
of you know wants to put behind what it
calls itself the century of humiliation
and feels that it was humiliated by the
West so there's a shift of economic and
political power as well which I think in
itself would be destabilizing so yeah
it's a weird time and you you said you
use the word dodgy when you were talking
about some of those countries can you
just go into detail what you mean by
that dodgy yeah well okay so what was I
talking about Hungary or Italy or Peru
you know I mean I think in Hungary in
particular it's a while since I've been
there but you know one of the things you
do as journalists and maybe it's not the
best way of gauging a thing but you go
and talk to other journalists and other
journalists will tell you in in Hungary
you know people I've known for a few
years that basically freedom of the
press is its closing down I mean they
wouldn't that's not what the official
line is but it's the lived experience of
people there and and you look at some of
the messages that all ban is putting out
now I think that the the ref the wall
for the refugees was was was a pretty
brutal measure but there's some argument
about whether Merkel's policy was
sustainable in itself you know you could
argue that actually Western Europe is
tacitly doing some of what Alban already
did so I don't think in itself that was
you know people reasonable people can
differ on that but if you look at the
rhetoric that he's using in the campaign
it's pretty racist and it's it's
anti-semitic the whole thing about sort
of this hidden power which he attributes
to George Soros manipulate trying to
destroy Hungary
it's real classic sort of Central
European authoritarianism and Poland I
don't think is as far down the line
although actually it's the one that's
been prosecuted by the
being committed not hungry but that's
for internal in European politics but
things that things are changing in
Poland and there's also this kind of
looming presence of Russia which I think
you know we thought of Russian
interference konstantin and it affected
the american election and i think it is
you know the russians are quite astute
at picking off bits of the EU and
including hungry and maybe grease a bit
and so yeah that contraband also just
are generally a slightly menacing
presence and i think that sort of
slightly contributes to this sense that
things are beginning to fall apart as
well as brexit of course well what do
you make of the whole russia thing
because one of the interesting things
for me that i've noticed is that since
the screep affair this is the poisoning
in Solsbury actually a lot of other
stuff has started to come out and the
british government is now investigating
14 other poisonings and other
unexplained deaths boris berezovsky
and other people for what do you think
has been happening and what do you think
is gonna happen with russia goes well
look i mean i'm not doing the
investigation but obviously you know
that was an example of good journalism
by a BuzzFeed actually putting together
that list of 14 people which had been
sort of circulating and then most people
were not paying attention and there was
a sense that the Brits were kind of a
bit reluctant to really go into it
because what do you do and you know do
you really want a full-scale
confrontation with Russia and also those
financial interests at stake that we
know about what are the financial
interests well I mean Russians are big
investors in in London in London
property flirtations of Russian
companies you know on a depth Deripaska
for example just floated up you know his
company on the stock exchange
so Russian money's become important you
know there's a lot of you know there's a
host of penumbra of law firms PR firms
merchant banks etc who will have you
know for whom the Russians are quite
important clients or happy well this is
what I was going to ask you because my
impression is from the figures that I've
seen actually as a country Britain
doesn't do a huge amount of trade with
Russia from what I understand no but
what you were talking about is there
kind of what you might call vested
interest within the establishment is
that is that the breakdown is that why
we're not perhaps being as strong in
Russia as we might the other
look I mean I would lie I don't know how
I saw dancers I don't know I mean I
don't know quite how these decisions are
made or so on but it's certainly the
case that Russian banks and finance ears
were capable because they were you know
individually had big deals and money
attached to them capable of making
influential friends in the West with
with who wouldn't necessarily want to
fight with him
I mean famously I like Deripaska had
this party you know on the yacht where
Mandelson turned up and George Osborne
showed up and you know Deripaska always
has this big policy in Davos as well and
everyone shows up you know that so
they're quite good at kind of becoming
part of the scene using yeah yeah
absolutely
and smoothing with with with money
attached and and the money seems clean
because it's like it's and above the
board contract well apply you to like
the company or whatever you know give us
PR advice and so for that reason there
certainly would would enter into
people's minds well do we necessarily
want to put this at risk it's quite
interesting talking about Russian going
to into detail about it how worried do
you think the Americans are by Russia
and what they're currently doing at the
moment it's which Americans I mean you
know I mean the interesting thing is
that because America is so part is
divided down the middle that there's
half the country the Democrats the
Hillary Clinton for hands who are
convinced that the Russians interfered
in the election and uh and the
Republicans really don't want to believe
it for their own reasons and within that
I mean that's and that's interestingly a
kind of reverse of the Cold War where
traditionally the Democrats as the
center-left party wouldn't have been as
hawkish on Russia and the Republicans
would have been the people banging the
table on Russia now that's changed but
within that there all sorts of
interesting kind of breakdown some and I
think that the FBI who are quite kind of
professional and who knows
you know as as kind of white men the
leadership of the f5b I what you would
say their demographic profile would be
their big quite likely to be Republicans
or over to trump
but they they are pursuing this and I
mean I had one an interesting
conversation was that about 15 months
ago with somebody who that kind of X
spoke in America who who was a hated
Trump but but but B was very exultant
that Robert mullah had been put in
charge of this because he said you know
this guy is very very tough very
professional home leave no stone
unturned and it's really bad news for
Trump that that this guy is on its tail
and so I think that that that although
there's all this hyper partisanship
within that there is a kind of hard core
of kind of professional Secura Kratz who
are genuinely offended by what they they
see they think this is all happening and
you're convinced that the Russia was
involved in the American election yeah I
mean you know to what end we don't know
and to what level we don't know I mean
it you know I mean they weren't trying
to help Hillary Clinton I think that
much although they were trying to call
social disarray generally so that if you
look at what's already come out you know
the early indictments by Muller they
were for example trying to stage black
lives matter demonstrations because they
just wanted a sense of social disarray
and social conflict within that clearly
they were they were pro Trump now what
level you know how much we don't know
how effective we don't know and that
probably is an unanswerable question
because you know why people voted or
what little thing it was that but you
know I was I remember I was at the
Democratic convention in Philadelphia in
July of 2016 and it was it was a chaotic
beginning because the emails of the then
head of the Democratic Party Debbie
wasserman-schultz I think had just been
released like two days before and she'd
been slacking off Bernie Sanders aneema
internal emails and this caused outrage
amongst the Sanders supporters so the
first day of the Convention was chaos
because every time a Clinton person took
to the stage they were booed shorts that
just had to resign and I remember doing
you know much as you're interviewing me
now I interviewing a mate of mine had
worked in the Obama administration
raishin and there was already some
indications that being a Russian hack
and we did this interview and I look
back at it and we were in a way as
curiously innocent we were just saying
gosh you know if this was really the
Russians that's really quite something
[Laughter]
it was just the beginning and then there
was this other League of the pedestrian
males which again came out of actually
crucial time just when Trump was being
pursued over the sex stuff like within
hours the Podesta emails were dumped and
so that yeah they you know potentially
it was we was well done you know in a
technical sense and I think it's pretty
clear that Muller thinks it was from the
Russians via but then you know the
connections become really fascinating
one of the interesting things for me is
I can feel myself becoming conspiracy
theorists I used to like laugh at
conspiracy it's rubbish whatever partly
because my mates weren't I think
conspiracy theories happen or you become
a conspiracy theorist when you feel
powerless and when you think God you
know that shouldn't happen you know this
is outrageous they all know each other
and sort of my group very very broadly
termed was sort of in power you know
people I knew would be University with
me all kind of felt familiar it shared
my discourse to use whatever they what
they were
and now these kind of maniacs are
empowered from you know what's going on
and so since you're on the outs
you suddenly thinking oh my god you know
X knows why and why knows ed and maybe
I'm making all sorts of dodgy you know
false connections but I'm going to give
you an example I did this I did a lunch
with EFT which is kind of like set-piece
interview with a mate of trumps and that
the attraction for me was that we did it
in moral agro you know in in Trump's
Club and and then you know this guy
Italian guy comes over and oh you know
he's the northern league's organizer in
in in the US and he's also Trump's
neighbor and then you know we get
talking to another guy who's just come
back from seeing old man in hungry dot
and what you know you wonder whether
also sort of like come on so what they
know each other lots of liberals know
each other or think actually there's
something quite
and I didn't quite know where I am on
them well a curious thing sorry Francis
before you jump in when you're talking
about how the people that you knew were
in power kind of broadly your circle
yeah without making this personal what I
was kind of thinking is well isn't that
why brexit and Trump happened people
were kind of going there's a small elite
who are controlling everything or
managing everything or in power and we
need to change that do you think that
that was what caused it look lots of
things caused it but I mean yeah I think
the thing about elites is that they tend
to think they've got there because they
deserve to be there I mean what do I
mean what's the group okay so to give
you an odd example like the only I mean
I like sounds frightfully well I don't
but there there was the only time I've
ever sat in a room with Hillary Clinton
for an extended period was oddly enough
it's a complicated story but I ended up
watching the Women's World Cup final
with her in her tail room in Greece with
a bunch of like her entourage and you
know people who were traveling with her
she was on a trip and I need she watches
soccer she does well I think she had to
watch it because it was American beer
was women and so and her daughter was in
the crowd so you know the only time she
got interested was when the camera would
pan over to Chelsea sugar butt and then
you know actually I think she was
desperate to get on with some work but
you know she was kind of tight well tell
me you didn't explain the offside rule -
no but then when it went into extra time
they then had to watch that and penalty
but anyways I try can you start again
keep yeah so no so you know just
chatting to the people they're like I
was struck I mean actually quite a good
thing for Britain how many of them in
being educated in Britain or spent time
there all walks for graduates or
whatever so it's this kind of Harvard
Oxford
you know chucking a bit of Goldman Sachs
or whatever you know that this group and
I don't see it as particularly sinister
but I can see if you want sort of
outside you might think I don't like
that hmm I mean it's interesting isn't
it I mean Trump essentially marketed
himself as being a man of the people
yeah whereas when he started his company
he got a million dollar loan so from his
dad
yeah absolutely I mean do you think that
we're gonna look back on Trump as being
a profoundly negative thing for American
politics or is it slightly more complex
than that well I mean you know I'm so I
think yeah I think I think it's really
bad but what I do think is you know it's
kind of weird because of you know a lot
of all have done history at school or
university you know if we're also if
humanities still around in 200 a time
people will be writing essays on what
the hell happened how did Donald Trump
win the presidency what did it mean and
we're you know just as they write essays
about Jefferson or the American Civil
War it's a huge event what just happened
and it's very early to try and assess it
but I was struck you know when I on a
recent trip to America and I did you
know my tour of establishment mate so I
did Washington New York Harvard's
and speaking to kind of cross section of
people and and they were very divided I
mean there were none of them were Trump
fans there was a group of sort of super
optimists about America who said you
know it's it's not good but he'll lose
American establishment it's institutions
are very powerful this company is very
grounded it's fine not fine but it'll
we'll get through it and then there's
another group who say oh my god were
kind of tipping all the way into fascism
and you know American democracy is in
serious serious trouble and this could
end in you know civil conflict or an
erosion of America's democratic
institutions which we won't come back
from and then there's obviously those
are the two polls but there's that
there's a that second group the real
alarmists are not sort of idiots they're
you know professors here and there or
people involved in politics and then you
know within that there's a whole
spectrum of opinion and I don't know
which
look III suspect that that Trump is in
one sense in aberration and then you'll
get more normal presidents after that
but that he's done
lasting damage to the discourse of of
the way Americans interact with each
other the way they think about their
institutions and that's where I think
that you know the whole Russian thing
comes back I mean because I think that
part of what Russia's narrative is is
that you know there's this clear this
clear-cut distinction that they like to
make in the West between democratic
countries with the rule of law and
undemocratic countries which so kind of
you know a jungle that's wrong
everybody's at it you know all
institutions are rotten and you know
better than us and that's their kind of
argument and to the extent that
Americans start buying there and saying
actually you know what the FBI is rotten
yeah we do have a deep state yeah you
can't believe anything you hear on the
news that's really corrosive and I I
think were slightly better off in
Britain but only slightly because
obviously brexit has been incredibly
divisive but I think I enlarge the BBC
is still so broadly respected there are
some institutions that most of the
country think okay they're impartial we
kind of trust them
but so I think America's further down
the road to that that really corrosive
sense which means in the end you don't
have a society if you don't have a
common version of truth a common version
of institutions that you can say okay
we'll allow those to arbitrate and we'll
all accept it you're in trouble it's
very interesting that you're talking
about America in this way and then you
were talking a few minutes ago about
China being in the ascendancy do you
think the fact that people voted for
Trump is actually a reflection of the
fact that America are no longer the
world's greatest super parent it's sort
of a crisis of confidence to some extent
I mean I think yeah you know that Trump
is one of the first presidents
successful candidates I can know he had
a very pessimistic narrative I mean so
that you know having now being fairly
ain't in 54 I've seen a few presidential
elections and generally that the winning
candidates the optimist so Reagan is
mourning in America Bill Clinton's the
boy from hope Arkansas you know and and
Obama is that you know we can change
when the change were seeking there's no
red and blue America and everyone goes
yeah yeah it's Trump saying you know the
country is being dissed
it's carnage he says in his inaugural
speech and this is our last chance to
rescue ourselves it's incredibly dark
vision and all that used to be like very
unamerican and the fact that as small as
friends put it a large minority of
Americans voted for it because of course
he didn't win um you know the popular
vote but enough to win is it's quite
disturbing but actually I think that
that's not just a side point about
liberals sort of kind of complaining
that he didn't win I mean I think it's
one of the signs of trouble in America
is that we've now had two presidents in
16 years elected without winning the
popular vote because george w bush got
beaten by al gore which is a sign of the
the level of gerrymandering in america
as well which is also a problem
so getting we touched on earlier on in
the interview about anti-semitism
anti-semitism in you saying it was on
the rise do you think that it's going to
rear its ugly head in a major major
fashion as it's done before or do you
think it's it's going to be something
that's always there in the background
more or less look I think it's one of
the way sorry did you say it was on the
rise well I know I think I mentioned it
in Hungary but I wouldn't I wouldn't
actually disagree with you you think
it's on the rise in this country I don't
know about that but I think it's what's
happened is that it's become a political
issue in the West I don't know whether
you know if you took a poll of what
people's sentiments you could say there
were more or less anti-semitic but what
has happened is that one of the weird
things and I'll you know I'm Jewish is
that it was quite nice I was kind of a
fortunate generation of Jews for whom
like it wasn't an issue a political
issue people weren't ride the side of
the barricades on this and there was a
sense that well we've got past it and
you know the 1930s and the lessons have
been learned and that was it and now you
know suddenly whatever the rights and
wrongs of the dispute in Britain as you
know it's at the heart of an argument
about what's going on inside the Labour
Party but you know people in the UK have
been understandably very focused on that
but if you pull back a bit
there are similar arguments taking place
in France the week that Corbin was being
dragged over the cause of this there was
a march of thousands of people in Paris
because of a murder of a Holocaust
survivor who the president McMahon said
very bluntly was murdered because she
was Jewish she was killed by a couple of
young Muslim neighbors and and then of
course you have this all banned election
where it was kind of explicitly
anti-semitic rhetoric and then a
slightly odd debate and you know in
America about is Trump anti-semitic now
I'm I feel about that is well if we send
a Semitic why did his daughter convert
to Orthodox Judaism it's not like a
standard anti-semitic move but it is the
case that Trump vie Bannon got a lot of
support from the outright and on that
fringe the fringes of the far-right sure
there's anti-semitism I mean one way of
looking at it you know
in quite simple terms is that I don't
think anti-semitism already exists in
the political center but it has existed
on the fringes the far left the far
right and as politics becomes you know
the extremes come into the center as
they've done with Trump and you know
some would argue with the Labour Party
they bring in maybe some some tropes
that were not not used in in in other
more centrist forms of politics I'm
curious about the article you were a
recently by anti-semitism and actually
the the interesting thing for me
particularly was less than two semitism
but more what you said about identity
politics and your context of it and it's
right throughout this interview and
other things that I've read I always get
the sense that you are kind of limp
you're a liberal yeah well you know with
occasional reactionary instincts and so
I was surprised to read something I'm
agree with entirely which is what you
said about identity politics which is
you said it's a threat and you said it's
a liberal can you elaborate on that and
why you think that is and yeah and
actually interestingly as well how does
that fit within the elite circles within
which you operate sure well I mean I
think that so why why is identity
politics a liberal because I mean I
think that liberalism is essentially an
individualist creed and says that people
should be treated as individuals in the
sense that they won't have the same
rights we don't say well you're part of
this group so you're in a subgroup if
we're citizens of the UK or France or
whatever we have the same rights under
the law but also I think there's a sense
that we are all to some extent should be
free to choose our own end identity you
know you see it now in sexual politics a
lot that people can say you know they're
I have fluid identities but even a you
know I was talking many in a political
context that I kind of I've always felt
uncomfortable with the idea that people
say oh you're Jewish so therefore you'll
think this about Israel you'll think
this about that you don't know what I
think actually and I'm not I am Jewish
I'm also lots of other things you know
I'm British I'm you know I've have a
certain sort of education I've a certain
class background a personality you know
all sorts of different things and so I
don't want to be almost like your whole
individual person yes exactly but and I
think the thing about identity politics
is it says well the key thing about this
person or whatever it's that they
remember the the Muslim community or the
Jewish community or the LGBT community
or whatever and this community we know
has this set of views and this this is
their spokesman and you know that's how
we're going to do politics and I think
that a I don't just don't like that way
of thought I also think that it gets
potentially dangerous because I think
when you start saying the X group the Y
group you encourage people to think in
communal terms and therefore to look
down on the out group or to fear the out
group and say well the only people I
really trust are members of my group you
know the other group we're gonna have to
negotiate with or defeat or something
and that's really dangerous
it's fascinating you said you were
talking about and it's also fascinating
you bring up it's gone back to
anti-semitism do you think that the
Israel's current policies in Boldin's
anti-semites and sort of gives it a
justification well do you complicate a
question but I think yes and no is the
answer to that I mean I think that there
are there's a lot of legitimate disquiet
both with the actions of Israel actually
interestingly with the idea of the
Jewish state which I'll come back to in
a second but the actions of Israel I
mean obviously it's if you see a kind of
bombardment of Gaza or something all of
our kind of liberal insets say oh my god
this is horrific you know they're kind
of citizens you know individuals
children being killed it's outrageous
and people get upset about that the only
reason I sometimes feel uneasy about it
is that I think that you know if say
Israel was doing now what this Russian
and Syrian Air Force has been doing in
eastern guter or you know did in Aleppo
whatever London would be in flames there
would be huge demonstrations people feel
very very strongly about it when it's
the Israelis and if it's the Saudis or
the
Syrians I say you don't even notice yeah
and you sort of think well you know
there's a kind of odd double standard
here and whether that's anti-semitism or
just that people think that in some ways
I think it's partly because they sort of
feel that Israel's part of us I mean
there's some of its anti-semitism some
of it might be well this is a kind of
white nation that we're allied with I
don't know but there's something odd
going on then the whole question of you
know it's a slightly until maybe I've
intellectualized way of it but one of
the things that you hear in this whole
anti-semitism debate is people saying oh
well you know it's fine to criticize
Israel it's not okay to question the
existence of a Jewish state and that's
that's the line now I know what they're
getting out but in a funny way
intellectually I think it should be okay
to question the existence of a Jewish
state because it's an it's a it's a
state defined by ethnicity rather than
individuality etc etc maybe that's
that's that's not okay and I certainly
you know I have Israeli relatives who
believe that the ultimate solution is
not a two-state solution but a one state
solution in which you have Jews and
Palestinians as Co citizens in this
country and a lot of Zionist would say
that is antes Israeli because it
eventually dissolves Israel's identity
as a Jewish state therefore it's racist
I don't think it's racist but I do think
personally that it's 9 then it could
have pretty dangerous consequences there
because I don't think that two
communities are likely to live together
in peace so I support a Jewish state for
largely pragmatic reasons I think it's
the best way if you can do it alongside
a Palestinian state of finding some kind
of modus vivendi but I don't think as an
intellectual construct that it's racist
to question even to question the
existence of Israel I do think however
you know it gets complicated because
some people who do that ah and Semitic
and I'm doing it from a kind of
intellectual basis you know are we
comfortable with the idea of an
ethnically based state you know there's
something about Israel itself that gets
to them do you think Trump putting
saying that Jerusalem is now the capital
is inflammatory or do you think that was
a the right thing to do no I think it's
inflammatory and it's intended to
enflame yeah you know
Bannon who was the guy who
was behind this and into amusingly is
often accused of anti-semitism because
of the people he mix with was very very
keen for the Israeli capital to be
acknowledged as Jerusalem that's been a
sort of totemic thing for the far-right
in America though you know hard right
and I think yeah it's pointless because
it's there's enough grief in that part
of the world without stirring it up
further it's a symbolic gesture which
will just upset people so I think it's
correct to say that that's a step that
has to wait for the ultimate peace
settlement which may never arrive but
it's nonetheless it's sort of giving
Israel the reward for the two-state
solution before the two-state solution
happens so I don't think it's a good
idea I'm curious to come back to the
identity politics because I think one of
the interesting things I recently found
out I have some Jewish heritage could
have told you that thank so you send it
you send off a little DNA sample two
weeks later you're Jewish your IQ goes
up by about 10 points it's great so I'm
curious about it because from a identity
politics standpoint Jews actually don't
fit the narrative of identity politics
very well because the idea of identity
politics is were all oppressed at
different levels and Jews I mean
historically probably the most oppressed
ethnic group ever and yet they're
largely very successful you're a good
example of someone like that right tend
to be very intelligent well-educated
successful financially right so that
doesn't seem to fit the narrative and I
don't ever hear about anti-semitism as
being part of the things that we need to
fight with in the identity politics on
what are you beginning to hear honey I
mean you know in Britain for example
it's suddenly become an issue but but I
mean yeah maybe that's a sign of the
kind of slightly disturbed political
times that we've entered that that this
kind of thing is popping up again and
it's interesting you taught you touched
I mean the far right we we know because
of history and all the rest of it and
you you mentioned that the far left and
obviously this is at the moment people
are talking about whether labor are
anti-semitic whether korban is
antisocial how
the far-left been anti-semitic okay well
look I mean I think first of all just
from a theoretical level the thing I
argued in the article is that I think
the far left are some of the many were
drawn to identity politics you know that
they think in terms of like the the X
community the Y community and I think as
I said that's it's a fact a slightly
dangerous way of thinking because then
you can say well there's this and then
there's this other group the Jews and we
can either be like Pro them or anti them
or whatever but they but they're this
group you know that we and I prefer
actually to say you know there's there
are individuals some of whom were Jewish
but I wouldn't lump them together as a
group but how is the left and he in
other in more practical terms look
there's been traditionally an
anti-capitalist element that's going
back to the 19th century and some of
times that gets mixed up with
anti-semitism you can see it action on
the right
weird it's funny both the far-right have
a Jewish capitalist they hate who's
George Soros the far left how about
Jewish capitalist a who's that the
Rockefellers you know going all the way
back but this idea of finance and the
sort of network of kind of international
network that's all kind of connected but
part of that is funny I did yeah I I did
once go to a conference where there
bunch of fairly powerful people and they
were all sitting weirdly in alphabetical
order and I was talking to a French
academic who said I hope there's no
photograph coming out of this because I
am between Rockefeller and Rumsfeld and
no and I think the other thing is that
obviously the the far left have taken up
Israel as a cause and as we were just
saying that there are there are ways of
doing that that uh sort of completely
legitimate I was gonna say kosher
license and then there are ways of doing
that that that then slide into a sort of
crazy conspiracy theories about you know
when the Jews were born to leave the
twin towers on 9/11 and that kind of
stuff for example one of the people that
call Ben
unwisely entertained at the House of
Commons is somebody who believes that
you know put out that theory so do you
think Corbin is an anti-semite I mean I
think probably not but you know also
it's a funny thing you know what's in
people's hearts it's hard to tell you
know I song to a sort of Jewish friend
of mine is said look the guy says he's
known to see my can we just like take
his word for it you know if he goes
around saying drive the Jews out but if
he's not doing that then fine you know
rock you don't have to sort of divine
his sentiments so I would be inclined to
say he's unwise since the company that
he has kept the company of people who
peddle pretty nasty stuff but he's not
said it himself
all right we've done enough on the Jews
I can say that I'm Jewish now I can say
anything I want so now you'll be rich
and successful yes highly unlikely
despite my Jewishness curious thing for
me is we always like to ask at the end
of the show what I guess think is the
number one issue that everybody should
be talking about that no one is talking
about it's a non answerable question I
mean I think we've we unfortunately
they're only up the number one issues of
the kind of obvious ones for me but
that's cuz I've got a I'm lucky in the
sense that I write about all the things
that are really interesting I think you
know brexit and Trump I mean sometimes
you think I can't face like waiting back
into that particular sort of cesspool
but but no I mean I write about the
stuff that I think is interesting and
it's been difficult for me to actually
break out of the Trump brexit Trump
brexit saying partly because one of the
weird things about modern journalism is
you know exactly how many people read
each article so you know you know what
what readers are interested in and
they're interested in Trump and brexit
our readers anyway and so I did a sort
of duty column where I went to Tunisia
which is an interesting country it's
like the last democracy and in the
Middle East that survivor of the Arab
Spring and I thought okay I'm gonna
write write this column it's important
nobody will read it I was totally right
and you know a reward for talking I know
well here's another question then let me
ask you this
you were one of the first journalists
that is coming on our show and we've
really appreciate you coming on thank
you very much tell us what is at its
best
what is journalism supposed to be what
is it about look it's hard to answer
that question without sounding absurdly
pompous but look I think it's about
something that we used to sort of take
for granted but it's now increasingly
under challenged it's just like trying
to establish the truth it's quite quite
important and that's you know and I
think that the whole Russian thing is
quite an interesting challenge to the to
the truth because we think you know
Sonny I have mentioned I joined the BBC
and people associate the BBC with
objectivity you know you use this guy
says this and this guy says that and you
report both sides
fair enough what's wrong with that I
think the Russians have played that
rather cleverly so they say like I would
say this microphone is blank and they
would say no no the microphone is
actually white and you should report
that I say it's white and also that it's
possibly yellow and green and I said no
no no no two sides to every story yeah
question more is right you know so so
you throw up so many kind of crazy
theories that you you can kind of drown
the truth you can cover the truth and so
we're having to rethink like well what
is it about actually reporting correctly
and sticking up for the truth is it just
saying well the Russians say this and
the Brits say that and why you know make
your own map is that even possible
Gideon because we've talked throughout
this interview about your own views on
yeah yeah what I mean oh no no of course
I'm paradoxically in the opinion
journalism things so I'm and that I had
to learn in a funny way because I
started coming from a conventional
journalistic background where you kept
kind of kept your own views out of it
correctly and then suddenly I was on the
op-ed pages and they actually had to
tell me at the Sun pointing tap me on
the shoulder say look you know your
analysis is all very interesting be
meant to have an opinion you know can
you say something and I had sort of had
and it's dot and some people that's very
natural to you know kind of you know
your piers morgan's etc who are just
mouthy and loved and it didn't come
brain naturally to me and in a way still
but I had to kind of teach myself to to
say something and even if I didn't I
never say anything I don't believe but I
will sometimes put it more strongly than
I would if we were just chatting in the
pub you know you make an argument and
and I think that's part of for me that's
part of the role and I don't
particularly my well obviously prefer
people say that's brilliant
but I realized that part of the game is
all part of the the role is to put an
opinion out there and then people can
say well I read there I disagree but it
but it sort of makes them frame their
own view it sort of contributes to the
debate and that that's part of the firm
that's part of the kind of odd bit of
journalism that I'm in well that's
exactly what we're trying to do here is
bring in people with different opinions
who can put it in an elaborate way for a
long time and actually have a chance to
you know explain what they think so
thank you very much for coming in it's
been an absolute pleasure and we look
forward you to put in the time before we
finish is there anything that you would
like to promote Gideon would you like to
know your Twitter handle for instance
ruk there are enough lunatics following
me on Twitter now yeah people want to
buy my book it's called Eastern ization
so it's been and you also wrote a book
about zero-sum politics as well did you
know anymore
no I did it's it's sort of that was that
was the one I wrote just after the
financial crisis saying that you know
there's gonna be trouble politically and
I think that was broadly right and if
people want to follow you on twitter or
instagram constantine where would they
look for you add constants and kiss and
I've got lots of Russian BOTS following
me yeah
and I'm at failing human Instagram and
also if the Russian bots are tracking
you I just want to say I disagree
you